[Música]
Aló
el mundo tiene la mirada fija en Ucrania
que parece una amenaza militar y una
invasión rusa hoy nos acompaña para una
entrevista al jefe de la diplomacia
europea josepurel vicepresidente de la
comisión Europea
alto representante de la unión para los
asuntos exteriores y la política de
seguridad
hablaremos acerca de la posición y las
iniciativas de los europeos
Buenas tardes señor borrell nos acompaña
en vivo desde la comisión en Bruselas se
había imaginado que Vladimir Putin iría
tan lejos en esta invasión de Ucrania
se lo dijo al presidente
y aquí estamos
durante un consejo europeo
extraordinario los 27 estados miembros
anunciaron sanciones financieras que
califican como masivas pero no parecen
convencer a Vladimir Putin En todo caso
no más de lo que las sanciones
anteriores le impidieron entrar en
Ucrania
la invasión de putina Ucrania pero le
harán mucho daño a la economía rusa sus
efectos se sentirán a corto plazo pero
sin duda no será pasado mañana
evidentemente no habíamos pensado que
estas sanciones fueran a frenar la
guerra pero la Unión Europea utiliza los
medios que tiene medio económicos
financieros diplomáticos políticos
no somos una Unión militar actuamos a
nivel civil y tomamos medidas fuertes
para aislar a Rusia del sistema
financiero internacional para impedir la
financiación del gobierno ruso para
detener las exportaciones de todos los
bienes que son muy importantes para su
desarrollo industrial y tecnológico y
sancionamos es decir prohibimos los
viajes congelamos bienes de varias
personalidad de rusas
durante esta reunión de los 27 todos los
antiguos países del este se hicieron oír
de manera muy firme en particular
Polonia se ha hablado también de
prohibirles a los rusos el sistema de
pagos interbancarios
todo está sobre la mesa nada se ha
rechazado de manera definitiva pero
estamos siguiendo un enfoque gradual
Ayer no hubo el consenso necesario para
tomar estas medidas Eso no significa que
no la tomemos más tarde
que la Unión Europea trabaja por
unanimidad
ahora el consejo de ministros de asuntos
exteriores que debe aprobar formalmente
el paquete porque el consejo europeo da
orientaciones políticas pero no toma
decisiones concretas somos nosotros los
ministros en el consejo
de hecho se dice que desde el round
anterior es decir en crimea en 2014
Vladimir Putin tomó la costumbre de
desligarse porque cortó sus vías de
suministros de ser más autónomo a nivel
agroalimentario
reconstituyendo su agricultura
reduciendo su cantidad de dólares lo
cual lo hace bastante menos sensible a
las sanciones financieras
Rusia ha desarrollado mucho su sector
agrícola de hecho es el único aparte del
gas y del petróleo que funciona y Sí hoy
en día es un gran país exportador de
productos alimenticios en particular de
trigo
también es cierto que aumentó sus
reservas exteriores
pero las sanciones económicas
ahí donde nuestras capacidades si
dejamos de exportarlas a Rusia le harán
daño al desarrollo de esos sectores
punta evidentemente no a la agricultura
[Música]
los países vecinos de Ucrania ante todo
Polonia
temen una ola migratoria de los
ucranianos que huyen del país por miedo
por supuesto de esta guerra
es posible que ese flujo potencial de
migrantes ucranianos se utiliza un poco
como arma híbrida como lo vimos en el
caso
no es un arma híbrida cuando hay una
guerra las personas se van evidentemente
hay ucranianos que se van a ir y haremos
lo posible por acogerlos
lo discutimos y la comisión y mis
colegas que están a cargo de la política
migratoria están preparados para ayudar
a enfrentar un flujo migratorio cuya
importancia todavía no conocemos pero
eso no es un arma híbrida
eso es Simplemente que cuando hay una
guerra en Ucrania en Siria en donde
usted está las personas se van
los alemanes suspendieron el gasoducto
nordstrim su certificación está
bloqueada no obstante los europeos
dependemos un 40% del gas ruso será
complicado para el invierno nos han dado
la certeza de que no faltara nada pero
al mismo tiempo tal vez tengamos que
pagar muy caro esta energía
aumenten los precios de los productos
energéticos
aumentan los precios del petróleo y del
gas
pero una cosa son los precios y otra
cosa son las cantidades hay una relación
entre ambos pero pagar más caros una
cosa no tenerlos otra
por ahora tomamos medidas buscando otras
fuentes
otros suministros para enfrentar un
hipotético corte de suministro rusos
pero por ahora no lo esperamos y en todo
caso tendríamos los medios para
responder a eso
Emmanuel habló del ataque más grave a la
paz a la estabilidad de Europa de un
giro de la historia de Europa nuestras
democracias están demostrando ser
perecederas sobre todo si no saben
defenderse contra regímenes autocráticos
muy determinados
el presidente macron hizo una excelente
intervención ayer
la conferencia de prensa que dio Me
parece que resume muy bien lo que nos
está pasando
la guerra está de nuevo a puertas de
Europa
pensábamos que eso era algo del pasado
nos acostumbramos a la paz y renunciamos
seguimos renunciando a la guerra como
manera de resolver los problemas entre
los países entre los estados
y ahora un estado con una potencia
militar fuerte invade a su vecino que de
hecho se defiende con mucha valentía con
mucha fuerza amenaza con utilizar armas
nucleares
no lo ha dicho de manera tan formal pero
todo el mundo lo entiende a todos los
que quieran interponerse en ese
conflicto
Entonces sí es una página en la historia
de Europa desafortunadamente entramos en
una etapa mucho más peligrosa a la hora
de enfrentar un conflicto las
democracias siempre tienen procesos muy
diferentes para la toma de decisiones no
como los autoritarios
es la voluntad de un hombre en una
estructura vertical de poder que decide
sin preguntar demasiado que piensa la
gente
por fortuna en las democracias tenemos
en cuenta la opinión pública tenemos en
cuenta la voluntad de la gente los
dirigentes no tienen todo el poder y los
procesos de toma de decisiones son más
lentos y más complejos eso nos hace más
débiles No eso nos hace democráticos la
democracia tiene la ventaja de que las
personas pueden evaluar y cambiar su
gobierno
no es el caso de los regímenes
autocráticos
Sí pero al mismo tiempo se podría decir
que nosotros también Éramos un modelo
para los ucranianos para todo ese flanco
Este y hoy en día nos preguntamos hasta
dónde ir a Vladimir Putin a moldavia
Georgia ya tiene abelarus
reconstituirá la antigua Unión soviética
tratando de influenciar absorber
controlar a los países que primero eran
parte del imperio zarista y luego de La
Unión soviética
Qué pasará ahora en Ucrania Cómo
terminará esta historia
los ucranianos están luchando y están
luchando con mucha fuerza y valentía el
ejército ucraniano no ha caído y los
combates son intensos evidentemente no
sabemos Cuál será el resultado pero los
ucranianos están resistiendo
Muchas gracias josep borrell por haber
estado con nosotros en francés 24
gracias a nuestros del espectadores por
habernos acompañado en este tema de
Ucrania
[Música]